>>Students: Ready?
Three, two, one, go!
>>Mary Krenke: I feel like
I have seen a difference.
The kids are more confident
in using the technology
when they bring it back
into the classroom.
The students can see it
all relates together.
>>Donna Barrier: The way we use
our technology is very purposeful.
We try to make that integrated
as much as possible
so that everything students do
is pushing them towards a goal.
>>Brooklyn: We learn how to, like,
edit pictures and make slides.
>>Lily: And if we want to make,
like, a presentation or a doc,
then we hit the apps button.
>>Michael: Well, we get
to videotape ourselves
on green screen or use "wevideo".
>>Donna Barrier: Last
year was the first year
that we actually had a technology
teacher in the building and at
that time our focus was on
exposing children to different apps,
but it was still a little
bit in isolation
from what the teaching
was in the classroom.
>>Jeff Dahl: What we've been working
on this year in the second year
of the program is we've been
trying to integrate more
of the classroom curriculum
into our tech time.
So, I've been meeting with grade-level
representatives and talking to them
about what are they covering in class.
>>Mary Krenke: In fact,
we have a Google doc
that it basically is
just a communication way
of "This is what's coming up in our
curriculum and what can you do?"
or "Can we have some ideas that maybe
you're able to add on in technology?"
>>Beth Rickerman: For example, if
they're working on stories in writing,
to have that flow into, you know,
his technology time as well.
>>Jeff Dahl: Okay, we're
gonna start a new project.
We're gonna start working
on scar stories.
It's non-fiction, it really happened,
and it's story that belongs to you.
A narrative is a story, a
personal narrative, your story.
We want sensory words, feelings,
touches, tastes, smells, sounds.
Action is key!
And then the "So what?
Who cares?"
You crashed your bike; so what?
What did you learn from it?
>>When they have a contextual
tie to what they're doing
in class I think it lends validity.
I can take those opportunities,
teach them a tool,
and hit content information
at the same time.
>>Okay, are you doing green screen?
>>Yeah.
>>All right.
Come on. Let's do it.
>>That's good.
Perfect.
>>Cassidy: When I was
little, like three or two,
I hit my eye on something
sharp in my kitchen.
I had to go to the emergency
room at the hospital.
>>Jeff Dahl: We purchased a green
screen set this year and we're looking
at color keying technology in some
of the video apps that
are available online.
>>Great job.
Nice job, Cass.
Hey, start thinking about what are
the images you want behind you.
>>Cassidy: The green screen's
gonna change my background.
It makes it look a little bit
more real and interesting.
>>Brooklyn: We're making slides of
different pictures of what happened
and then you can either edit your
face in by doing the green screen
or you can just, like, voice do it
so you don't have your face on it.
>>You're gonna go voiceover?
>>Yeah.
>>Yeah. What was the accident?
Think of one that really stands
out, because those are the ones
that you're really gonna
have good details on.
>>Mallory: Well, I was in a car and
there was a motorcycle behind us
and then there was a car with a trailer.
Then the trailer got
out of control and..
crash! There was glass everywhere
and it scratched me a lot.
>>Jeff Dahl: That's awesome action.
Go into presentation mode
and see what it looks like.
>>Donna Barrier: It's not just about
substituting programming for something
that we could've done in writing.
It's to be able to give
students additional ways
to express their learning, to
go out and find information,
pull that together, use their own voice.
>>Jeff Dahl: You're the author,
if you don't like the way
it looks, put it back.
>>Donna Barrier: We want all of
our students to learn the content,
of course, but we want our
student to learn how to be learners
for the rest of their lives.
That ownership just pushes
them to work even harder
to produce that good end product.